hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
perhaps you remember the review of the
Cloverfield trailer that I did last
summer
is it Donkey Kong
my money's on Donkey Kong maybe it's
Jesus maybe it's a giant robotic Donkey
Kong Jesus riding a puff of smoke
hilarious
well January 18th has finally hit and I
feel only necessary to talk about the
film that I ironically helped promote so
what is it that's terrifying all of New
York in the middle of the night well
I'll tell you what it is a monster just
a monster not Donkey Kong or the Second
Coming it's just a monster it's not even
a famous monster like Godzilla or Rodin
or a thing it's just a monster no twist
no backstory no surprises
just a monster bullshit all that
build-up all this time all that effort
just were fucking monster suck my dick
if I want to see monsters I go to the
DMV to get my license renewed
hell you don't care about what it is all
you wanna know is is it a good movie
well let me tell you something
this film was okay just okay not good
not bad it's just okay how was the
monster it's okay how's he acting it's
okay
how the special effects it's all okay
it's like a giant flaming nuclear ball
of adequacy so if you like shaky cameras
and monsters going there chances are
you're gonna like Cloverfield in fact I
probably just reenact the movie for you
right now just using my handheld camera
if anything hold on oh my god there's a
giant monster outside things are blowing
up and
can't hold the camera straight I was
just at a party who were only the most
beautiful people New York to show up and
others and do all these days Anthony
look outside someone to dad of the
Statue of Liberty boy who would do that
a monster yeah it is it's so big and
horrible it's kind of hard to explain
what it looks like
I guess you just have to pay the eight
parts to see it in the movie theater
that's it that's actually kind of
ingenious I'm just gonna shake the
camera and uh scream some more oh yeah -
mm Butchie pretty project now I'm gonna
take a minute out to have a dramatic
moment
oh man it's all gone it's all gone
okay Mull it over dreaming yelling
screaming yelling ahh oh my god the big
monsters at you spitting out little
monsters oh my god it was bye to you and
your head actually explodes actually
that's pretty cool oh my god he killed a
lobster if they actually killed it they
destroyed it in the city Hollan oh wait
no they didn't fire
oh my god imagine he's about to eat me
his dhoti beaver Tsubasa
oh my god he spat me out he's bad little
oh my god he spat me on to the island
from lost Locke Locke did you see the
giant monster he was so creepy hey is
that guy from Lord of the Rings really
dead I like that guy he was cool
and that's pretty much the movie well
except for that last part that that may
not happen but you get my drift it's
pretty much just a monster movie nothing
else if you like monster movies you'll
probably like Cloverfield but wait a
minute what about the title in my last
review I said that Cloverfield was
merely the co board for the movie and
not the actual title but then they
slowly started advertising in his
Cloverfield so what the hell well
according to them the video that
documented all this was codenamed
Cloverfield so that technically the
movie doesn't have a name just like I'm
technically not gonna fork over eight
more buts - technically see this film
again screw you mr. Abrams you and your
quid filmmaking I'm in this Tyler Critic
I remember it because it's that wait
you